professor Myers is going to be speaking
about sort of lessons more or less from
her you know cities from
come up Kirk maternity jeans geography
from New Zealand with an x field and
urban planning minor sets an MA in
African area studies of geography and
urban planning as the major and minor
fields NPA with honors in history from
building college he has taught at the
University of Kansas University of
Nebraska Omaha Omaha Miami RC Ohio
California State University Dominguez
Hills any feelings so he's been all over
he's comfortable with large lecture
classes and small seminars that and I
thought this is wonderful his teaching
philosophy rests on a belief in student
engagement the best learning as we know
these places engage classrooms and
that's something we could talk about in
our pedagogical sessions as well
my assessment research in Kenya Tanzania
lobby's MBA Senegal South Africa Finland
in the UK we're going to pass 20 years
and he really uses this research for me
so we hope them thank you
[Applause]
well it's nice it's nice to be here
coffee really helps I didn't want to do
my third cup before I talk because you
know that point
I'm sure it's teachers you have that
point where you've had too much coffee
and and it's well it for me I have the I
have reached that point and I think I'm
just going gangbusters and talking
brilliantly and actually no one
understands a word of what I'm saying so
I and I'm also coming from a workshop at
the posse foundation in Chicago because
I'm beginning a role as a mentor for the
Trinity students who are coming from
Chicago through the posse foundation
thank you
as Posse scholars and it's it's it's a
it was a great experience to be in the
workshop but the highlight of it was
meeting the ten students that I'll be
working with who come from disadvantaged
backgrounds from the city of Chicago so
it is a someone who's focused my
research on our urban Africa this last
couple of days was and yet another
example of the sort of commonalities and
and and threads of connection between
what's going on in Chicago for these
young men and women and and what's going
on
in the places that I I study I wrote
myself a little a little blurb too to
read out to you before I get into my
actual talk because I was listening to
Martin I was thinking we could very
easily overlap and we edited a book
together and so we have sort of had
mind-meld moments in our career and and
some of the things that Martin said are
very much what I would have said - the
first thing though is and I say this
every time I speak to remind myself and
whatever audience I'm talking to about
Africa I say Africa is huge diverse and
complex as a continent the 48 states of
the United States fit inside the outline
of the continent three and a quarter
times so it's a massive continent it's
diverse we have more than 50 countries
we have more than depending on how you
count conservatively more than a
thousand languages other people will say
more than 2,000 languages and these are
very different languages from one
another so it is not the case that these
are dialects people will make a
statement about the bond to languages
there are more than 800 bond to
languages that these are different
dialects I'm fluent in Swahili I have
made a stab at learning Cheney on Gia
it's not a dialect of Swahili
there's about 20 words that are the same
but some of them means something else so
it's about as different as you know as
French is from English you know there's
there's commonalities between those two
languages but just because I speak
English does not mean I know French so
III remind myself of that especially
today because I'm making a lot of
general remarks about African cities and
then looking at the lessons for US
cities and the themes that the tyover
and so I'm assuming most of you are
coming from the US maybe not of a US
background or US born but I would assume
many of your teachers in the US and just
think for a minute of how different US
cities are from one another and then
multiply that by 50 or at least by three
and a quarter to contemplate how
different African cities within one
country or within any of the 50
countries are from from one and other
and I've done research of some depth in
eight of the cities of Africa and there
are more than 50 cities on the continent
with more than a million people and some
of the ones that I've worked in or not
cities of a million worked in Zanzibar
dar Salam Dodoma and Tanzania Nairobi in
Kenya Dakar Senegal Lusaka and Zambia
Lilongwe in Malawi Cape Town in South
Africa and I've done some in-depth
research and written about some other
cities that I haven't actually been to
Lagos Accra Kinshasa
Buju and HS in in in Senegal so I'm
continually humbled by how much I don't
know I've written four books and
co-edited to others on urban Africa the
one with Martin as well and these have
covered the gamut my most recent one
that just came out is called urban
environments in Africa and so it's
looking a look into some of the issues
you were talking about in regards to
climate change or air quality but I also
have written a book about solid waste
management in Africa and a book about
colonial influences in in terms of urban
planning and get this Martin I you know
this because I think you you've praised
it a book called African cities which
several of my friends have chastised me
for but it was to my I guess I would say
it was my inattention to the the
insistence by the publishers that I
title it book that way because they
could market it because there is this
thing called Africa and they have cities
so their African cities despite the
diversity and complexity so I'm always
learning alongside all of you I just got
back from the Pearl River Delta in in
China so they're China cities of
Guangzhou dong Quan shinjin and Hong
Kong and one of the things that I was
doing there was examining and talking
with the African communities along the
way at Guangzhou has the largest
community of Africans in China probably
in Asia on any given day there's
probably about a hundred thousand
Africans in Guangzhou there's more
likely about 18,000 to 20,000 permanent
residents of African origin but even in
that community it's an incredibly
diverse and complex community each
little part of the the Guangzhou African
community has its elections they elect
their own presidents and by far the
largest about 49 percent of the
population is no surprise what country
do you think
Nigerian but by most people's estimates
the second largest population is
Congolese and not coming from the
Democratic Republic of Congo but coming
from the former French Congo the
Republic of Congo and the third largest
from Mali these are not countries that
have a long-standing record of relations
with China these are not countries that
are connected over a thousand years of
trade with China like like Kenya or
Tanzania would be there are various
reasons behind it but when you go into
these warehouse centers and you see the
clocks on the wall telling what time it
is it's Beijing Bamako Brazzaville maybe
because it's all B's but that's that's
who's interested in what time it is
so that surprised me I was not prepared
for for that even to contemplate a
Malian trading community of that size it
certainly is something I expect and see
in Senegal but so my guess my lesson
from this is to to be mindful as I talk
for for you and for myself of the
unfinished quality of what I'm talking
about
the the speculative nature of all of the
understandings that that I'm going to
give you and this is a particularly
provocative sort of talk that I wanted
to give especially given what's happened
in the last few days I'm gonna start
though with someplace else other than
China or other than than Hartford this
comes from the political scientist Nick
Cheeseman who's at Oxford and as a
Britain was voting on on whether to exit
from the European Union which they
eventually did but before the vote had
actually taken place Nick Cheeseman who
works on Africa wrote this brilliant
satire of how this would be covered if
it were happening in Africa and I just
got this little segment here the
divisive language used by a number of
political leaders has revealed deep
tribal and Reid
cleavages and shown a new light on the
country's fragmented and incoherent
national identity in a state that is yet
to do away with its royal family that
allows unelected traditional leaders to
wield great influence through its
legislature that's his type on that line
of the many overlapping ethic and
regional cleavages at play one of the
most significant is the ongoing tension
between English nationalists and
Scottish succession is so you can see on
where it goes from there it's a it's a
rather long and involved in detailed
essay it's actually well researched and
it's dead-on because this is how so much
of the rest of the world looks at at
Africa and so following on what Martin
had to say we see the sort of
perceptions and perspectives that people
from outside of Africa have on on Africa
cities as being different as being
others being not quite cities who are
not real cities they don't work and some
of what I loved about that video that
Martin showed is just to say we just
slap you in the face and say look it's a
city you know it's got the same problems
and other cities have maybe some new
ones maybe some different nuances of
things but let's sort of strip away the
other ring process that takes place when
anyone mentions Africa so what I'm
attempting to do is to look at cities
the other way around and I look at this
the this way because in urban geography
and urban planning urban studies in
general this the city I just came from
and arrived at 2:30 in the morning from
Chicago is ground zero you study the the
Chicago School of urban studies if you
are like me and you had advisors like I
did at UCLA then you move to the LA
School which is where I got my PhD
strangely if there's not really in
sociology there is but not in in
geography there's no New York school
which is weird because it's the bigger
of the three but
cities like like London and Paris and
Chicago Los Angeles that give the
prevailing notions and models and
theories and ideas of how cities look
how they grow what happens in them and
why the patterns and processes of
urbanization so that's that's fine
that's where a lot of our thinking comes
from but that's not where the world is
today
that's not where urbanization processes
are taking place
Hartford added between 2000 and 2010 I
think they added 116 people to the
census number and meanwhile most of the
world's most rapidly urbanizing
countries are in Africa and having just
come from Hartford sister city I'm not
making this up of don't Kuan which how
many people have ever heard of one
it's not a city that very many people
have heard of but 30 percent of the
world shoes 30% of the world's shoes are
made in dong Quan said he's stuck
between Guangzhou Hong Kong area and
that's Hartford sister city because
whenever that relationship started they
were about the same size and similarly
you know industrially based now don't go
on has 8 million people in Hartford a
hundred and twenty-five thousand so when
we look at cities in Africa we look at
cities in China these are the places
where cities are happening cities are
changing and what happens if we if we
just change her bin' studies and we
start thinking about cities not in
relation to the loop in Chicago or or
Manhattan but let's think of it in terms
of what's happening in Eko Atlantic
village that's the model of urbanization
good or bad that's happening in the
world
so are there lessons then from Africa so
most of the time in urban studies all
the lessons come from China I mean I'm
sorry all the lessons come from from
London or Chicago and they're passed
into China and Africa and this literally
happens cities that I've studied like
like Nairobi or Dar es Salaam their
first official master plans who are
under British colonialism they were
based on the London plan so you know
these are literally the ways in which
urban planning was established in Africa
was through colonial lens so if we turn
this around what what do we see on the
one hand I think we should acknowledge
there are potential ways in which you
could argue for these cities in Africa
being incomparable with cities in the
United States that certainly has been
the trend that I saw people very puzzled
in the urban geography of the LA School
with what I studied my Swahili book was
called by a major professor in the
Geography Department
and UCLA lilliputian because he he
looked at it and it just looked like
some you know language from from from
Jonathan Swift I've never forgotten or
forgiven him for that
so and he certainly is one of the main
voices arguing for Ian comparability
well okay there are some points here US
cities are definitely wealthier than
most cities in Africa as a whole there's
a whole lot more infrastructure industry
and and a municipal service provision
that happens in in most cities in Africa
most cities in the u.s. in comparison to
cities in Africa there are a lot of
people who study global in world cities
and they make these statistical analyses
of of the impact of globalization in in
cities around the world that when they
first started doing these in the in the
1990s there were no African cities at
all and then they slowly plugged in
Johannesburg and then over the last
decade with an onslaught of criticism
from people like Martin and myself
they've included more and more African
cities but they used the the global and
world cities group at Loughborough
University in the UK they use Greek
letters okay so another element of
Eurocentrism so they have Alpha Beta
Gamma cities and they have alpha plus an
alpha minus so it's just like grades
right but with a Greek letter system
guess where the African cities are
there's you know Johannesburg will crawl
into that a - right
if you're lucky Nairobi I think because
it's got so many UN headquarters offices
it's a beta city you know but most the
African cities are either in the gamma
category or they're in this sort of
thing that I call honorable mention you
know like they took a pass/fail and they
get you know they get listed as they
have some globalization happening but
you know we're not gonna really study
them look at airline traffic you look at
foreign direct investment all the sort
of main trappings of globalization in
Africa's off the map
that that's a potential reason why it
would would set up to study uh African
cities differently or to say well
they're not really a part of this story
and the third one is when you look at
cities in the u.s. you see in many
cities a broad process of
deindustrialization some of which is
linked to two suburbanization and this
the the spread of industry into suburbs
some of which is linked to the spread of
urbanization to places like China I'm
betting that you know those shoes that
are made in dong Quan fifty years ago
were made in Maine and were made in you
know in New England somewhere so
deindustrialization is a big story
suburbanization a big story of US cities
over the last certainly of my lifetime
and you look it up again you see rapid
urbanization you see a lot of downtown's
that still matter
yes sir these new sort of gated suburbs
being built but suburbia of the Western
European or especially North American
variety doesn't seem to matter quite in
the same way in Africa certainly most of
the poor of urban Africa live in rural
in and edgy areas that we would call
suburbs so those are potential areas for
incomparability and I I'm not going to
deny that there are differences there
certainly definitely exist but I think
there are a lot more commonalities and
the patterns and processes have a lot
more to do with each other
there are a lot of economic social and
cultural processes that I see as being
similar and today I want to take you
through just seven that I picked out
these are just the the seven I'm
interested in there could be others and
and the way I take it through there are
biases that come into it because I live
in Hartford because I work in Hartford
and then
I have experience in the eight cities
that I have so some of what I see may be
because of the cities that I have worked
in in Africa so that's why I put it at
the bottom there to say it's my African
urban studies perspective not really
necessarily common to to everybody else
this is what I what I call and I think
it's still legitimate to call an article
that I published two years ago the
unexpected the comparison because when
people do a comparison of cities it's
typically of cities that are seen to
have things in common that are seen to
be similar enough to be compared or they
provide this contrast but they're on the
same page so the more famous studies of
the process of globalization by
sociologists like Saskia Sassen will be
studying Tokyo London New York somebody
else might study you know New York
Chicago Los Angeles because those are
cities that are viewed as as having
things in common to study so it's an
unexpected comparison to say let's
compare Nairobi and Hartford or let's
compare you know Johannesburg and New
York these are not typical in urban
studies I think when we do that we have
a lot of lessons to learn and I say this
specifically because I live in what is
one of the most divided cities in the
United States as you'll see and I'll
talk about and one of the most divided
cities in the world and and yet when you
hear about Africa and you hear about
Africa cities you hear about this
incredible poverty you hear about this
incredible new fancy malls being built
so there's incredible inequality as well
as incredible poverty that's the sort of
defining feature of what a lot of people
will see or say or talk about in
relation to Africa so if that's the
claim to fame
my heart those the cities we study when
we come back to Hartford and say gee why
do we have you know 42 percent of the
children living without health insurance
and we have you know forty five percent
of the population living in poverty and
we have all this violent crime what are
the ways in which we can study a city
like Hartford coming from African again
my bias comes into it because as an
urbanist my career has been studying
cities in Africa it's not been studying
cities in America I've just lived in
them so the first aim of my comparison
is really just to illustrate that these
are comparable situations and here are
the themes that that I plugged in and
I'm gonna go through each of them in
some detail but colonialism and I put it
in post here also we'll talk about it as
neo colonialism poverty and inequality
and then thirdly an underfunded corrupt
local government fourthly violence and
insecurity but then I I try always to
come around to a much more balanced view
of things particularly because there's
so much of African Studies
that is as fallen into what is called
afro pessimism this notion of the the
failings and the dystopian visions of
Africa so I always am mindful that
that's not the experience I've had in
Africa that's not the experience that
most Africans have and so I look for
some other things to talk about in in
relation to connecting Africa African
cities with with a city like Hartford
and these are the three I have here
spiritual and metaphysical cityscapes
cities of innovation and creativity and
then cities of cosmopolitanism and trans
nationality I think these are features
that really define every city I've
worked in in Africa and they certainly
define Hartford so here I've got post
and neo colonialism I don't know how
much all of you have learned this week
or no
but every country in Africa except for
two experienced formal European
colonialism anybody know what the two
exceptions are Ethiopia and Liberia and
just think about those exceptions a
little bit right Ethiopia was occupied
by the Italians for seven and a half
year period and Ethiopia as a as an
empire was circumscribed because they
lost the territories they claimed of
Eritrea and Somalia and Djibouti and
half of Kenya to the incursions of
colonialism so they were certainly
affected the the independent country of
Liberia lost about half of its territory
to to colonialism and itself was founded
by outsiders and so it has within it a
very divided society between people who
have names like Charles Taylor the
former dictator of Liberia who was a cab
driver in Boston and graduated from
Northeastern University in Boston so
that's not necessarily something that's
absent of colonialism and it's in its
own right so pretty much you can say
everywhere across the continent there's
been an influence of colonialism and
even 50-plus years now after
independence most African cities live
with that hangover because those cities
were built for the purposes or
transformed for the purposes of colonial
rule to exploit those territories to
extract resources the infrastructure I
always use railroads because the
railroad lines until the Chinese started
building new railroads in Africa the
railroad lines all around the continent
other than South Africa ago mine to a
port mine to a port mine to a port or
you know Plantation area to a port
plantation area to a port that's it
there's no connecting railway lines
there's no interstate highway system of
most African countries because the
colonial regimes didn't invest in
not and then I always take my students
through the the chocolate bar because in
any given year West Africa produces more
than half of the world's raw cocoa and
like one chocolate bar and a billion and
then take the Snickers bar into it the
peanuts the sugar it's all coming from
Africa but the bar itself is produced so
we talked about French roast coffee we
talked about Swiss chocolate or Dutch
processed cocoa
you know but the products themselves are
all Africa based so Africa cities live
with that sort of colonial hangover but
you know what so do many American cities
if we think about it in a in a different
sort of way and it's especially poignant
right now to think of Hartford in this
way because Hartford is very staunchly
and strongly a Puerto Rican City and
Puerto Rico just was signed over to an
oversight board that most of my Puerto
Rican friends view as neo-colonial that
is deciding on Puerto Rico's future and
the connections of Puerto Rico and
Hartford are very strong
one of the few places outside of the
continental United States that you can
fly to non-stop and direct and send what
from the Hartford Airport and then you
have all the other Caribbean people from
from from Jamaica from Trinidad from
from Dominican Republic who make up a
significant population within Hartford
and then I just throw in since we're
still in Connecticut many people from
Connecticut will know this but other
people who may not again depends on the
revenues and they've been following but
a sizable percentage of the state budget
of Connecticut comes from the revenues
paid into the state budget by the
casinos of the Pequot and Mohegan
reservations in eastern Connecticut so
even the indigenous people who are
virtual
nonexistent in the demography of
Connecticut still play a major role in
the the funding of the city so there are
ways in which this notion of colonialism
and post colonialism that is so dominant
in the understanding of Africa cities is
very relevant to my mind to to cities in
the u.s. at cities like like Harford
poverty and inequality there's a measure
that we use in development studies in
economics it's called a Gini coefficient
I'm not going to get into the details of
it some of you will probably have seen
this before it's a measure of income
inequality it can be used to measure
other forms of inequality as well but
income inequality on and it's normalized
to a number between 0 and 1 and so most
of the countries in Western Europe when
you look at the Gini coefficient of
income inequality of the cities of
Western Europe the number is somewhere
around point 3 to 0.4 there are no
cities below point 3 in the world that I
can think of of any significance you
always can have inequality so 0.3 is
considered to be a very low rate of
inequality many cities in Africa have a
rate between point three and point four
in their Gini coefficient of income
inequality the major exceptions are in
southern Africa South Africa especially
Gini coefficients of income inequality
in South Africa lead the world more on
the scale of 0.61 in Cape Town but
that's that's actually down from where
it had been under apartheid these
numbers were you know 0.75 0.78 so just
unbelievable levels of income inequality
but most African cities are more in that
0.4 range most US cities are above 0.4
and we happen to have a number
of of the highest cities of inequality
in the United States right around us and
I'll get to that in a minute but a
Hartford which has a lower Gini
coefficient than some other US cities
certainly Bridgeport fare Fairfield
which is the most unequal urban area in
the United States on on most measures
but Hartford is also a place with a
metro area that's very massively wealthy
and there have been measures that have
come out that show it is one of the
world's wealthiest metropolitan areas so
what might not show up in the Gini
coefficient for the city itself shows up
when you look more broadly at the
spatial inequalities of the city which
are very much to me like you would see
in in Africa so Nairobi has a Gini
coefficient of 0.57 the most recent one
for bridge boys was 0.5 for 3 but it had
been at point seven five point five
seven New York City which is one of the
top five unequal cities the United
States and income inequality that's
equal to Accra and when we look at South
Africa which is off the charts but we
see cities in South Africa having the
Gini coefficient going down they have
lots of problems in cities in South
Africa but as Martin was suggesting with
that rising middle class black
population that's a key feature of
decreasing the Gini coefficient so if
we're concerned as it seems to be in the
United States with inequality as a
rising issue in our cities why not look
at a place like South Africa not to say
cookie cutter let's take what they did
and do it in Connecticut but let's say
what lessons are there for cities in the
United States of a society like South
Africa and Brazil is another example
where you have declining Gini
coefficients are there any things that
have been done
there that seemed like not such a bad
thing this just gives you a little map
about you see some cities around it's
New Haven's not so so hot a little bit
lower than Hartford and then Fairfield
at the top of the charts and there are
other measures and other elements of
this as I said you have you know more
than 40 percent of the population living
below the poverty level in Hartford you
have by some measures half it's gone
down to about 40 percent as I understand
it because of Obamacare but somewhere
above forty percent of all children
lacking health insurance and this is
Hartford Connecticut which is the
insurance city it's one of the most if
our first shows up on those charts of
global and world cities it's for the
insurance industry obviously so when we
look at cities in Africa we say they're
unequal and there's there's severe
issues of poverty what what can we take
from those cities and apply in in Africa
I mean in Hartford just to give us a
space because I'm a geographer of the
spatial aspect of this this is a rough
outline of the boundaries of the City of
Hartford and it's very fundamentally
divided between a black north and a
Latino south with a scattering of white
population a very very tiny Asian
population and a white West End and the
suburbs overwhelmingly white 78% of the
metropolitan statistical area of
Hartford is right and about 14% of the
city itself is white we see a spillover
effect as a growth of black middle-class
the United States leads to cities like
Bloomfield and Windsor to the north of
Hartford becoming significantly that the
school systems in both of those cities
now have a black majority so we have
right you know in our own state here a
very significant case of segregation
which is something that as a scholar of
colonial influence
was a very clear and deliberate tactic
of British colonialism in Africa's
cities was it was it so clear and
deliberate in the United States it seems
something to contemplate and then we get
on to the corrupt and underfunded local
government let me first talk about
Africa we have long cases of people just
falling to get funding in cities to the
city of Dar Salaam when I interviewed
the city commissioner about 12 years ago
showed me a chart where they had never
ever in the at that point seven years of
existence of the City Commission they
had never received more than 76 percent
of the money budgeted to them by the
United Republic of Tanzania government
and that budget was never enough in the
my solid waste management book one of
the things that again if this was the
director of the dump pointed out to me
it's a city where they received all
sorts of accolades around the world for
their solid waste management program
that's why I studied it in in dar Salam
it went from three percent of municipal
solid waste residential solid waste
being collected and sent to a landfill
to 40 percent and in my interview with
the dump manager he said well let's
let's let's be real here
we're not doing all that well think
about it what happens to the other 60%
and you see it everywhere it's burning
around you it's it's in every ditch and
and he said and it just says 40 percent
or 43 percent goes to a landfill let's
go to that landfill I'll show you what
that landfill is like and it's not a
protected landfill nobody working there
has any protective equipment you have
just horrific things leaching into the
water supply right from that landfill
which is on fire
so these have real consequences in
people's health everyday and I like to
talk about garbage so as most people
don't but to me it's sort of a way into
if the city works its garbage is being
collected and and people are not dying
of diseases that are easily preventable
if you collect the garbage so in those
contexts most of the time African cities
have been forced into privatization
schemes of one sort or another not as
Extreme as what Martin was talking about
earlier but in the sphere of solid waste
the the World Bank and the donor nations
all came and said what you got to do is
privatize this you got to have companies
that collect solid waste and it sounds
great when you come from a capitalist
country and you've been raised in a
society where uh of course there's a
garbage man he comes with a garbage
truck from a company that's been
contracted to a city and they collect
the garbage and they take it away to a
nice landfill most African cities have a
sizable percentage of the population
living in informal settlements which
don't have roads which have paths or
alleys that are not wide enough for
those trucks so the first thing that all
those programs had to do was to start
community-based enterprises that would
have wheelbarrows to collect the waste
and then they had to have collection
points to get the waste out of those
neighborhoods so I'm not gonna bore you
with the more garbage stories because I
realize you know it's it's it's not
lunchtime yet but I don't want to ruin
your appetite but they very rarely
worked and in the case of dar Salam that
was so highly praised people very
closely involved in it would admit to me
in an interview it didn't really work
and I come to to Hartford you see
corruption
at every level in Africa and as Tony
Blair I'll give him credit put it in his
report on Africa where he more
infamously said Africa is a scar on the
conscience of the world pointed out that
when we talk about corruption we have to
recognize that corruption comes in all
different forms
if African governments are taking bribes
to allow development that means that
European companies or Chinese companies
are paying those bribes and expecting to
and are a part of that system but the
the level of waste that goes with this
is staggering this is from the Neo
Monument in in Nairobi which is just
across the road from Kabara which Martin
was talking about that is considered by
some people to sort of poster child of
an African slum has at least 300,000
people living in a postage stamp area
and right across the street you have
what the former dictator Daniel arap Moi
built as a monument to his philosophy
which is neo the footsteps but most of
the opponents of his regime would say
yeah footsteps following behind us and
and oppressing us but you see you know
it's aping the Washington Monument this
is a huge EEMA memorial you know and
it's just it's gone to waste now but
there was an incredible amount of money
spent on this sort of monumental ization
of of Moyes regime the main national
Central Park of Nairobi about half of it
was was taken up by the ruling party to
build their their headquarters it was
going to have another massive monument
many stories high to Daniel are Moy only
prevented through a tremendous amount of
grassroots work led by Juan Gauri Mata
who won the Nobel Peace Prize in part as
a result of her fight I live in Hartford
now and I don't know how many of you
follow the news but there's been this
ridiculous series of cases of former
mayor was a graduate of Trinity College
Eddie Perez is fighting his
his jail sentence for corruption along
with the former governor of Connecticut
John Rowland there's a long stream of
this this is why people call it corrupt
ik it right now you have an effort
Hartford had a major league hockey team
they lost it and there's been this
effort to get back in a sort of major
league sports can't do it so they're
gonna go for a minor league team
building this Park and Dunkin Donuts
Park and it is not completed looks a
little bit more completed than I thought
it would have when I googled a picture
of it but it's stalled and the team that
is calling itself the Hartford yard
goats will not play a game in its own
Park this year it was built in the north
end it was built through all sorts of
neoliberal schemes it was largely
opposed by the people of the north and
there were lots of promises of jobs and
development for the north and all of
which are predicated on all of the
hotels and retail and restaurants and
residential developments that would go
around the park none of which has even
broken ground and probably none of which
will and then the another Fiasco was a
an attempt to bring Major League Soccer
to to Hartford renovating a stadium and
and a man came and proposed that he was
going to renovate the stadium they would
play in the might the what's he called
the indoor soccer league for the first
three years and then the stadium would
be done and would only cost I don't know
seven hundred seventy million dollars
and the stadium would be done he took
his 1.2 million dollars for the the
development that he would develop and he
was gone and then is when the city
discovered that he'd already served two
different terms for embezzlement so you
know
I think when we talk about corruption in
African cities and we talk about weak
local government coming from the United
States it's a little two-faced and we
have a lot of questions a lot to answer
for
in US cities when we see the level of of
weakness underfunded school systems in
our cities and then you know lo and
behold we're going to make statements
about Africa cities having been
underfunded violence and insecurity is
something I think most people would jump
at about Africa that that's the you know
very common theme oh and this is a sort
of testimonial to that in in Nairobi
that I think is is really very touching
it's the memorial to the to the Embassy
bombing this is a spot where of the al
Qaeda organization blew up the the US
Embassy in 1998 there were two
hundred-plus usually most of them women
at a secretarial College next door in a
building that you showed in the slides
they a next door that still exists it
sort of half collapsed and so more than
200 mostly women secretarial college
students died and I think the way in
which America has memorialized 9/11 is
really incomplete without the
recognition of the first version of that
devastation which occurred on the heads
of Kenyans and certainly nabhi residents
recognized that highlight that and bring
that home as a means of expressing
solidarity with New York and connection
to New York and yet
New Yorkers I think for the most part
don't even think that way at all
so and we have we have a spate of urban
violence in the United States has been
rising crime in a number of cities and
violent crime in Hartford certainly
spiked up last year and has continued to
be to be high and we have the incidents
of the last few days I I like to point
out from my from my own research that
black lives matter everywhere and that I
think when we look at the the level of
police injustice in Nairobi in Zanzibar
which is going on every day in
Johannesburg these are connected and I
see my friend John SEL de Souza leads
the moral Mondays group and Connecticut
is the associate chaplain at Trinity is
going to Brazil
to make that exact point to say that you
know black lives matter in Brazil as
well and I think it's another way that
we can raise this conversation to talk
about Africa's cities belonging in the
same framework of discussion about
issues of violence and insecurity that
we see around us okay so I've got about
five minutes left so right okay so I'm
going to spend at least five minutes
talking about happy things or a little
more positive thing and many of my
friends in cities in Africa are very
religious but roughly equally divided
between Muslims and Christians even
those who follow other religions tend to
be very religious most of the continent
is very strongly spiritual and it's a
it's an overwhelming experience in an
African city when you live there whether
it's during a month of Ramadan in in a
Muslim City or in
the season around Easter in a Christian
City or both in cities that are both
like like dar Salam and it's it's lived
in an everyday way and it manifests on
the landscape and I just have two brief
examples of this and in Senegal there
are a number of different Sufi spiritual
groups about 90% of the population of
Senegal is Muslim and there are two
major Sufi spiritual Brotherhood's that
dominate the country the second largest
of these is actually the more famous one
this is the murid brotherhood because
the mureeds are the ones who are most
active in sending out traders around the
world and they tithe so they send money
back home to build the spiritual capital
of the murid brotherhood which is a city
called tuba a couple of hours north of
Dakar and the founder of the Murray
brotherhood cementing amadou bamba who
also happens to have been the founder of
the movement for senegalese independence
and once you start to know his image you
see amadou bamba every way this is this
is you know a father rama even some of
you will remember the the ritchie valens
song that was then redone in the movie
about about him la Bamba that was a
massive number one hit in Senegal
because people just naturally said oh of
course of course in America they would
sing about Bamba
so Obama's unknown at Senegal in that
song but is you know an incredible hero
to the Senegalese and and his image is
is everywhere as a sign of the the
spiritual Sufi belief system and this is
a little harder to read it's a garbage
dump so you can see huh I'm a little
obsessed this is one of those slabs so
you have the wheel bowels going through
the the settlement to pick up trash and
they were told to put it in this open
space because it was accessible by one
lane track by a garbage truck but as you
can see garbage trucks did not come the
trash is burning you can't really see
them but they're a number of Indian
house crows big huge black and white
birds eating the trash and
it took me a while to kind of unpack
this and talking to people but you'll
see in the background this small tree
this is a tamarind tree which is called
the key quad you and the neighborhood is
called key quad Zuni so this is the
neighborhood of the little tamarind and
this particular part of the neighborhood
is called him Z Moony the haunted place
of the ancestors which is right there
so you're never gonna get a garbage
truck to pick that up because these are
offerings to the portal to the
underworld that lies underneath it and
if anybody in the German Development
Service had talked to anyone who lived
there they would have said yeah it's an
open space but don't put garbage there
and now when people see garbage there
they see the crows as I said the crows
are manifestations of the spirits and
why would you ever even walk around that
neighborhood right so getting to see the
spiritual in the metaphysical cityscape
is really important in Africa I think
it's really important in Hartford I
think it's really important in all of
our cities and it's just one little
example of it in in the South End of
Hartford just outside of an Irish pub
is a memorial to Bobby Sands the hunger
striker of the IRA this is the middle of
Hartford alright and it's a very
important spiritual point for the
Greater Hartford areas significant Irish
population you have all sorts of other
things that I could throw in there
that's an overwhelming presence and the
cityscape of Hartford to see religious
landscapes whether it's Jewish or
Christian or Muslim Malcolm X founded
the the the the mosque in Hartford he
was arrested in Wethersfield was the
town I live in on his way out of town so
there are a lot of ways in which these
cityscapes are very much all around us
quickly these two you know in Hartford
you have this building built by Sam Colt
which is a factory you see rotting on
the side of the road it's now being
rebuilt into surprise surprise luxury
condos but it is also a part of the new
National Park which is the cult film
National Park to recognize the
innovations and creativity and industry
that made Hartford great the city of
Mark Twain and all of that and I think
we see that kind of creativity
innovation everywhere we go in Africa
several years ago there was a company
that was very successful until it kind
of got crushed by the government in
Kibera in Nairobi that was a toilet
company is there there was just not
enough toilets as when one of my friends
put it there are more NGOs than toilets
in Kiara and so this man built a company
around pay-as-you-go toilets and he call
it was echo toilet so they were so echo
friendly they were recycling reusing the
the waste is manure all these different
things that you know he just came up
with on the side sorry and we got to do
something about this this this toilet
problem let's do this
and we'll make money from it and we'll
figure a way to help out our gardens
so you see a lot of different elements
of the the imagination the fantastic in
African cities that I continue to learn
from and lastly coming from from dong
Quan and and Guangzhou seeing the level
of influence of cities around the world
on each other we live in a really
cosmopolitan time and this other word
just a pretty fancy of transnational it
trans nationality where where people
identify with more than one country they
are both and so many of Hartford
residents are both Puerto Rican and
American many of similarly more recent
immigrants to Hartford come from places
like Albania and Bosnia and they still
retain with social media with all sorts
of financial flows their connections to
those places and this is becoming more
and more the case and it leads me to
argue that you know and to think that
Africa cities belong to the world so we
we see the connections across you can go
you know it's it's largely Nigerian food
then the Nigerians think you know they
will one day conquer all of Africa so
African food it's it's a Nigerian
restaurant in Hong Kong but you look
here and you see now I said most of the
traders are Mallya and Congolese and
Nigerian
but the flags on the side of the
wholesale it's a quick flag test for you
it's teachers Kenya Tanzania Burundi
Uganda
Somalia Rwanda so it's all East Africa I
didn't actually see anyone from East
Africa and I heard three people speaking
Swahili but they were Kenyan so it's not
necessarily the case that this is a
large group but there is a block of
traders who come they don't necessarily
live there but they will come and buy
stuff there you see increasing numbers
of African urban residents learning
Mandarin it doesn't really help them in
Guangzhou which is a Cantonese city but
it's still it's still there and you know
you come I had to put this in you know
guards the art of cuisine that's from
the Hartford taste of the Caribbean
festival so you see an increasing number
of influences from around the world
including from Ghana which is the most
significant African population in the
Hartford area I was just in the car as
well and Senegal and the nickname of the
blue box Antonia in Dakar is made in
China in English made in China because
it's really becoming a Chinatown I'm
gonna stop there to leave some time for
questions just the last bit is to just
look wherever you are and cities all
around the u.s. Oh around the world to
not lose sight of the fluidity of
flexibility things are unpredictable
they're ever-changing and surprising in
cities I've spent a lot of time in New
Haven and it surprises me might not
surprise you if you're from New Haven
but I think it has its its its quirks
and intricacies as well and I would
argue strongly for putting cities on a
level plane analytically to not think
African cities are not quite cities or
they're different somehow yes they may
be less wealthy they may have fewer
elements of infrastructure but there are
there are things that we can compare and
especially in terms of elements of
policy
I'll stop there